(trumpet playing)
- [Narrator] Once upon a
time on the island of Sicily,
there was a race that ran
right through your village.
It was glorious.
It was beautiful.
It was clearly planned before
safety was a consideration.
The Targa Florio was founded in Sicily
by a speed loving fellow
named Vincenzo Florio in 1906.
And it enthralled the racing
world for decades to come.
But this was no ordinary race.
It took place in the
mountains outside of Palermo.
Racers encountered bandits,
wolves, 500-plus hairpin turns
on roads that hadn't changed
since togas were in fashion.
The course went straight
through towns and villages
with no barricades or warnings.
The first year a driver
named Alessandro Cagno won.
It took him nine hours
and his average speed
was 30 miles an hour.
The Targa Florio ran for 71 years.
Titans of the car world like
Mario Andretti competed,
but a growing realization that the race
was crazy dangerous led to
it being shut down in 1977.
It was the longest running car race
in the world at the time.
Today, the grandstand
outside Palermo sits empty,
but evidence of the race is everywhere,
peaking out in the beautiful landscape.
The Targa Florio became synonymous
with a long and grueling race.
In the years after its end,
tribute Targas have popped
up across the world,
but true racing enthusiasts
know it all began here.